هل يقود موظفوا جيل الالفيه درس كود غير
رسمي عنوان طرحته مجله فوربز اشاره الى ان
موظفين جيل الالفيه يقفون وراء الاتجاهات
الحديثه في دراستكود والميل نحو المزيد من
الكاجول فقواعد اللباس تحدد ما نرتديه
ومتى واين اما في ذلك المناسبات غير
الرسميه فحتى في حال عدم وجود قواعد
مكتوبه منصوص عليها بقرارات الا ان قواعد
اللباس الضمنيه تفرض نفسها وتكاد تكون
معروفه للجميع لكن العالم يشهد بين الحين
والاخر بذور افراد او جماعات او حركات
تعارض فكره بريستون
فهناك من يعارضها باعتبارها شكلا من اشكال
التمييز بين الناس واحيانا باعتبارها حملا
ماديا اضافيا يثقل كاهل البسطاء ويبدو ان
الاجيال الاصغر سنا هي المسؤوله عن هذا
التحرر النسبي لدرجه ان الاثر انعكس على
اكثر الموظفين اتباعا لقواعد الرسمي
الصارمه في والستريت وغيرها من اماكن
العمل المهمه
رحمه والتقليديه على كل حال المزيد حول
احدث ملفات الجدل حول درس كود مع النجاح
حجازي
قرار رئيسي مهرجان القاهره السينمائيه
حسين فهمي بان يكون لدرس كود ملزمه لكل من
يحضر المهرجان هذا العام فتح ابواب النقدي
والرفض على درسكم في مصر فكل ما هو مفروضا
[موسيقى]
لكنه ليس الوحيد
مهرجان وكان سينمائي الدولي في عام 2015
ادرس كود في جميع انحاء العالم بات عرضه
للشد والجد والنقاش فقبل سنوات حاول اربعه
نواب برلمان في الفلبين تعديل قانون سياسه
الباب المفتوح الذي يسمح لاي شخص زياره
المباني الحكوميه او حضور اجتماعتها شورت
ارتداء ملابس مناسبه النواب الاربعاء رؤوف
دراستكود فمن شانه ان يميز ضد المواطنين
الفقراء الذين يؤدون زيارته مبنى الحكومي
او حضور اجتماع لكن لا يمتلكون ملابسه
مناسبه
[موسيقى]
العماني الماضيه من وباء كورونا اللذان
شهدنا خلالهما الاغلاق والعمل والدراسه عن
بعد ربما ساهم في التعجيل بانهاء منظومه
الدراسكوت فقد استطعنا الانتاج والعمل
والدراسه والنجاح ونحن نرتدي البيجامه وقد
يعني ذلك ان مسمارا اضافيا دقه في نعشق
دراسكوت لصباح العربيه نجح حجازي القاهره
ومن افضل من نادر تراب لمشاركتنا في موضوع
قواعد اللباس زميلنا نادر استطاع تحقيق
لقب الرجل اكثرنا اكثر من مره وذلك على
هامش بطوله كاس دبي العالميه للخيول هو
معروف بحبه الالوان واناقته الملفته التي
نلحظها يوميا
والحداثه ويستحق ان يكون نجما للاناقه
منورنا في الاستديو وزميلنا العزيز المصمم
نادر يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
صباح الخير صباح الخير على كل مشاهدين
صباح الخير عليكم
لانه همم
انا بفتكر انه معظم الازياء في ال ال زي
الرسمي هي يعني بورينج صارت ممله واحنا في
في في صرنا في زمن انه يعني التطور سريع
جدا بالذات في عالم الازياء
السوشيال ميديا
والانفلونزا في السوشيال ميديا هما ساعدوا
في انتشار الترند في مجال عالم الازياء
ودي واحده من الاشياء اللي خلقت ثوره
كبيره جدا في عالم الازياء والعالم يعني
صار دوله صغيره كلنا ممكن نشوف الكولكشن
الفلاني اللي انا باحبه وانا حابب بس زي
ده في المؤسسه دي مادام هو ما باثر في
عملي يعني
اللباس التقليدي القديم كانه صار شويه ممل
يعني كما وصفته بس انا بحياتي ما شفتك مش
مغير يعني مش لابس غير بدله في الشغل
بس لسه بمسكين كمان بشعره مع الزي الرسمي
التقليدي يعني دائما في بدله مع عائشه
صارخ عم تعمل
لانه انا بحب الالوان وبشوف انه يعني همم
بيئه العمل بتسمح لي انه انا البس بدله
لكن ايش لونها هنا جري ايريا فانا بما انه
بحب الالوان بحب دائما يعني البس بدله
بلون جميل بلون همم راقي بلون شويه همم
يعبر عني فا ما بحبس بلاك سود بدله سوداء
بدله لون حرامات هذا النمط القديم القديم
جدا بما انه العمل سماح لي البس بدله
فممكن هنا وكمان يعني بتعطيني شعور جيد
انه انا لابس كده بتعطيني احساس جديد في
العمل وبتخليني يعني كمان نشط في العمل
لانه اذا انا حاسس بانه انا يعني همم
كلاسيكيه والحداثه شو نصايحك للشباب
يشوفونا اليوم والله انا نصيحي اول شيء
للشباب العربي بالذات لانه انا بحس انه
بيخافوا من مساله الالوان هذه هو طبعا
الانسان مش بخاف من اللون عشان اللون مخيف
لا هو بيخاف من الانتقاد اا اللون بيعبر
عن شخصيتك همم الشباب العريق بالذات انا
بحاول بقدر الامكان صح دائما يلبسوا الوان
لانه حرام في في الوان همم كثير بتمشي مع
بشرتهم بس هم بيخافوا من النقد الواحد
وخائف يلبس لون معين يعني يعطيك مثال وهو
في شائع جدا مش في العالم العربي فقط يمكن
في كل العالم همم في اعتقادي انه اللون
الزهري هو لون انثوي بس اذا سالت وين
مكتوبه
فقط
وهذا الكلام انا باشوفه غلط كبير جدا انا
عن نفسي همم
دائما دائما ممكن الواحد يجرب اشياء ثانيه
طيب نادر هل تشعر انه طريقتك الغير
كلاسيكيه في اللبس وهذا الفاشل بلوك بتحس
انه ممكن يحدك في وظائف معينه مثلا لو
اخترت ان تكون مذيع اخبار هل يعني ستتجرا
ان تلبس هذه الالوان او ستعتقد ان المؤسسه
الاعلاميه ستسمح لك بهذه الالوان على
الهواء
انا كذكر اعتقد لا لانه المؤسسات
الاعلاميه بالذات القنوات الاخباريه عندهم
الوان معينه اللي هي بتعبر عن عن عن
الوظيفه نفسها عن الاعلام التي تبع الشركه
يعني في اشياء لا يسمح بها ان تتغير يعني
زي اللباس العسكري لباس العسكري خلاص اللي
باسل العسكري ازاي المدرسي هو زي المدرسي
بالشكل الفلاني لانه همم يعتبر انه انت
بتعبر او انت بتشكل صوره بتشركه العملي
الفلانيه ففي حدود ممكن انا البس فيها بس
مش اثناء العمل
بس داخل العمل اعتقد لا لانه هنا يمكن
يكون قانون وقانون كمان شويه